let's go back to the saki story because
we never fully read that article about
what she said her comments uh so saki
confronted claims no economist is
predicting higher inflation from massive
spending bill the political insider nbc
peter alexander americans
are seeing their dollars their paychecks
stretched right now why should americans
not be concerned that injected
another 1.57 trillion dollars or more
would raise inflation saki answers
because no economist out there is
projecting that this will have a
negative impact on inflation saki said
on monday suggested the spending spree
would actually help combat inflation
oh my god
economists across the broad board will
say this will actually help reduce
inflation address inflation over the
long term she said if saki can't find no
economist who thinks inflation is a
grown problem she needs only
contact former obama economic advisor
larry summers who said we are going to
see inflation of a kind we haven't seen
in 30 years which is already happening
since 1991 we've been screaming a lot
today but let's give a a quick summary
for our wonderful audience and thank you
for being out there and if you like it
you know hit the subscriber there
there's three things and you can help me
here
three things that will help inflation
increasing the value of the money which
means increasing the interest rates
second is causing the government's
current deficit to be shrunk so the
government's
borrowing less and lastly is to shrink
the money supply those are not
republican or democrat things these are
just the aren't these just the sliders
that moderate inflation okay so and so
we just printed how much money and we
increased our budget deficit in the
current year by the spending so we ran
two out of the three really up to
redline did we not
we did what's important to realize
though is that the growth of the money
supply is what matters not the absolute
level of the money supply so in june of
2020 the money supply in the united
states was growing by 30 percent that's
collapsed to 3.8 percent because
congress is
paralyzed this is m1 this is and this is
m4 this is all this is the biggest
aggregate you can have so that's gone
from 30
the whole enchilada 30 growth rate down
to a 3.8 growth rate as of september so
we're not injecting more money into the
economy i'm actually going to do
something that
doesn't matter i'm going to i'm going to
reiterate what i said earlier patrick
what's that sac is right that this
particular infrastructure spending bill
is not in fact in fact tyler can you
pull up um can you pull up the
the quill again and go to the last page
the the my weak there you go look no no
the very last page that right there
that's when all this starts to kick in
it's like it peaks out in 2026. can you
explain to us what that is
that is
a 10-year infrastructure program doesn't
hold a candle to stemi checks
and
the money's going to trickle out into
the economy and as biden has told us
it's going to create lots of union jobs
yay
and this is why this will not in and of
itself ignite inflation because you're
not actually
going to get out there tomorrow with
private companies to make sure that that
you don't waste taxpayer money and get
these damn projects underway immediately
it takes a long time permitting
again you're working through unions and
so it's by definition going to be
inefficient
but that does not change the dynamics at
the ports that does not change the
dynamics about rental inflation it
doesn't change the dynamics about the
damn bacon
all of that inflation is very real right
now
but this is going to be like the obama
infrastructure plan was it's going to be
a scary site by the way
nothing
2026 is when we're going to see the
highest impact on gdp which peaks out at
just over 0.5 percent woohoo yeah but
you but you give people money directly
you direct deposit
five trillion dollars into people's
checking accounts yeah it's going to get
spent hey uh uh tyler can you do me a
favor and pull up the bloomberg article
about powell's five benchmarks for
inflation if you have that with you and
then i just sent you a picture as well
we'll cover that here in a minute on
what fauci just said which is pretty
crazy yeah bloomberg powell five
inflation benchmark and it'll come up
this is a story from yesterday there you
go
okay go to see if you can get rid of the
talk there you go number one are
inflation pressures broad-based in
august powell said in the spike in
inflation up until that point was
largely the result of price rises and a
narrow group of goods and services
directly affected by the pandemic that
no longer that's no longer the case
right so he was talking about across the
board beyond the usual suspects gasoline
okay fantastic go to the next one number
two our price rises moderating in those
goods and services that have experienced
the biggest run-ups so while there were
some signs that was happening a few
months ago it's no longer so clear-cut
yes used car price inflation has come
down a lot from it's 45.2 percent in
june though it's still running in excess
of 25 and mannheim just released new
data that shows that through the middle
of november every used car prices have
accelerated it just takes a little while
to show up in the cpi data so that that
25
it's it's going up okay so so that price
is going up and he says annual prices
rise for durable goods in general though
clocked in at 7.3 in september biggest
increase since 1981. okay fine let's go
to the third one third one third one
what is happening to wages powell told
that
the jackson hall conference that he saw
little evidence of wage increases
that might threaten excess inflation
worker pay has picked up since then as
employees have taken advantage of
plentiful job openings
to quit in record numbers in search of
better opportunities i know you got data
on that which we'll get to that here in
a second right after this so we believe
the u.s is entering the high tightest
labor market condition since 1950s holy
moly number four what is happening to a
long-term inflation expectations fed
policy makers pay a lot of attention to
what americans are thinking about prices
because officials believe that goes a
long a long way to determining what
housing goes if workers and companies
are fearful of prices spiraling onward
they'll act in ways that will be helped
bring out bring that about okay go to
the fifth one let's see what the fifth
one is uh number five is are longer term
global forces still pushing down
inflation over the past quarter century
inflation has generally been low in the
us and across maryland arizona powers
are going to continue there are signs
though that some of the forces may be
coming less powerful china's sticking it
to us no question about it because they
can't and no one's fighting back and
saying anything about it so okay so you
were talking about
labor forces of people quitting okay you
want to get into that there are two and
i think this is the last chart that um
that we're going to pull up from from my
weekly go back a page
focus in on the bottom right hand of
page nine
all right so you pay people a ton of
money to not work right
[Music]
so we have a deficit compared to the
prior and they don't right on queue and
prior to covid this is the trend line
the the yellow dotted line
we're 7.8 million jobs below that line
some of it's because people have retired
early
a lot of it's because people have gotten
used to not working
and a lot of it is also because if
you're an employer if you're an employer
and you see this 20-month gap
on somebody's resume is that an
attractive potential employee or do you
want the guy who's one of the 4.4
million who's like i haven't quit
working my skill set's hot i haven't
none of my workers i respect that have
atrophies yes i want to hire that person
so that there's the haves and the
have-nots in the labor force and the
have-nots have been taught to behave
like socialists we're going to pay you
to not work and then you're going to get
used to it so you're not going to work
and by the way you're not just going to
not work and we're going to pay you for
it you're going to be unemployable at
the other end while companies have
accelerated automation you've seen
investment in r d
and artificial intelligence any form of
software you've seen companies automate
out of existence millions of jobs
but if you have the skills
you can you can name your price
so there is a great big divide going
right down the middle skills always win
and it's so great but this is such a
great skills do always win but we took
skills away from people by paying them
to not work and now they're unemployable
yeah of course well of course that's
good policy why do you say that they're
unemployable when there's a work
shortage and people can't okay i'll ask
you a question if you have demonstrated
that you're going to run out on me
why why take a risk on you versus her or
do you have the basic skills
the question is whether it's a lot of
people she's going to be okay
what's the whole thing that we say at
dunkin donuts if you don't like the long
line apply for a job there's a lot of
people
that they don't want those jobs exactly
and there's something that we're not
talking about that we can and by the way
how many people are not going back to
their shitty ass jobs because they made
a billion dollars from crypto there's a
lot of young people that are 20 years
old that started investing in dogecoin
or in bitcoin or in ethereum and they
were worth negative
money and now they're
i don't think there's a lot of young
people out there that are not going to
go back in the workforce because they've
made money from crypto okay and i'm
happy for them but i don't think they
probably comprise nearly eight million
people i'm i'm just saying young people
okay a lot of young
so look there's a few things you can
take into account with that one is that
community but what percentage that's 7.9
you think that is yeah maybe 10
okay let's say a big number like that's
probably not that big of a percentage
it's probably three or five percent but
let's just say that's what it is sure
yeah out of the 7.9 let's take some that
are 65 and up 63 and up 62 an hour like
i want my social security now yeah and
they're just kind of like listen man i'm
out i'm good
tom you're gonna have the answer to this
question
what is the difference in income if you
collect social security at the youngest
age versus starting at the oldest age to
collect 62 versus 70 you're saying
how much does this my monthly check yeah
my monthly check is when i'm 65 is big
right but if you
you wait till you're seven it's way
bigger if you wait until you're 70. the
differential between the two is 30
percent yeah if you can wait waiting
five years yeah the longer you can wait
the bigger your check 59 and a half to
70. yes i'm saying if if you cover that
so a lot of people who left the
workforce early and started to collect
social security early have left a ton of
money on the table because they're
getting all these stimulus checks their
house is worth more than it's ever been
worth and they're like screw it i'm
quitting you know this is true i'm gonna
start collecting my social security
early but how's that going to feel in a
few years those people are going to go
back to work you know there was
we are going to see we are going to see
seniors come back into the workforce and
you know what they're going to be more
employable
than the younger people who have been
replaced i don't think so at all why
would older people be more employed
they're going to be more employable than
the person who was replaced by a kiosk
and companies have totally disagreed
companies have lamented the fact that
people who are 55 plus have
better work ethics than younger workers
these five people
who want flexible hours and they want
they don't want to come into the office
and they want to make sure that they can
i mean okay here's a little anecdote
talk about the 4.4 million who are
quitting their jobs buddy of mine runs
uh a huge logistics company
for
i don't know the biggest
telecommunications company in the
country but he runs a logistics division
so he has a new employee after two days
the guy quits why because he doesn't
like the color of the safety vest it's
orange
and he didn't like the even though it
was required to be worn on the floor of
the factory everybody it's just so you
don't get hit by a forklift everybody's
gotta wear the orange vest and the guy
after two days he's like i can get a
better job i don't like the orange best
pie i don't think he has to do it he
can't go get a better job he probably
just wanted a better job orange vest
wasn't the thing then why did he take
the job in the first place i don't know
i don't know who the kid is but you're
not gonna
what's the point of the orange vest tell
the story then he didn't like the way it
looked oh stop it
i'm not saying let me tell you
okay so do you think that's the reason
he left the job because the color of the
vest that is what he told us he told his
boss for 48 hours that's what he said i
don't i refuse to wear the orange vest
and the guy's like it's just but this is
where i'm going this is where i'm going
well you know where this leads me to
here's where this leads me to on what
she just said that's 7.8 million on what
he just said
and you look at that number and if i'm
amazon if i'm walmart if i'm any of
these companies i'm sitting there saying
uh we kind of got to figure out a way to
not rely on workers because they
complain too much they constantly want
more they want to do this they won't do
that sometimes automate
automatically
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]